book recommendations when your ex-wife's  husband dies in a suspicious ass  accident there's just this strange thing  that happened  um joshua died  [Music]  he actually um slipped  and fell joshua we didn't  always get along especially when you  were having sex with my wife  you know what the situation isn't even  suspicious okay  joshua's just a little clumsy boy  i was nowhere near the grand canyon and  i really hope  i can be steady comfort for debra  i did not kill joshua anyways i'm  supposed to  recommend the old old man in the sea  he's an old man i'm going to grow to be  an old man joshua won't because he's  dead  my kids are devastated if only it was me  they say  if only i had been the one who fell on  the grand canyon and died  i don't have any more recommendations  honestly like  i don't know what to tell you at this  point i have a lot of problems in my  life  i should probably just get a therapist  [Music]